we returned you to Sydney Australia
right now our police have stormed the
cafe in the central part of the city
where a gunman a lone gunman was holding
hostages
police say the siege is over Juliet's
ally is back with us on the phone Juliet
what can you tell us what's happening
right now what's been happening over the
past half hour well certainly since we
lost like Eric it seems that that police
then decided to really get this
situation to a head and we heard a
number of young shots and also it's
alleged that there was some grenades
you're on towards the cafe so a large
number of explosions heard across the
Sydney CBD just after quarter past 2:00
a.m. time so we're now heading into the
17th hour of what would have been a 17th
hour of the siege
we're starting to see some vision coming
through of police storming into that
cafe and taking out some of the hostages
on stretchers it looks like a couple of
people may indeed have been injured
whether or not that was from gunfire or
grenades or whether it's just from sheer
exhaustion of being held off you're nuts
a face for around 17 hours but police
rescue are also on the scene and we have
seen basically something that Sydney has
never seen before we don't really have
scenes like this we don't have guns in
Australia to say so it's not being quite
a frightening situation that saw unfold
but this stage it looks like police has
decided to really try and end this
speech no sign of the gunman as all yes
and to be clear when the police rushed
in to the best of your knowledge it was
not in response to anything happening
inside it was strictly an action to just
get those hostages out it wasn't like
they were hearing explosions before or
gunshots no absolutely not it certainly
looks like it was just part of their
tactical operations we know that police
have been keeping very closely for their
chest the way that they were basically
dealing with this situation the media is
well cordoned off as hour passes by
watching well away from
Lynch cafes so it looks like police have
just decided to take things into their
own hands as it started to enter a
second Bay so the footage that we're
seeing they've got those guns where you
can see the infrared you can see into
that cafe which all the lights have been
turned off and just a whole lot of
gunfire charged into that building so
you would imagine they had really staked
out where they wanted to target and
potentially well away from where the
hostages were sitting which we certainly
don't believe it in response to the
government just really trying to bring
these situations or ahead